hey you guys it's Friday and that means
it's time for another one of our 13
o'clock movie retrospectives now this
should be the last one the last movie
review that I'm gonna have to do without
Tom as I said on the regular episode on
Tuesday he actually had to or decided to
stay in Mississippi longer because his
dad's recovery was going a little more
slowly than expected but actually his
dad is doing much better and Tom should
be back in Florida tonight you know than
the night that this review goes up so
from this point forward subsequent
episodes in subsequent movie reviews
he'll be back on them and thanks to
everybody that has given your support
and sent me messages asking about him
and stuff like that you know everything
is seems to be going fine and he will be
back soon
and so since he is not here again for
this movie review I decided to take the
opportunity to do another movie that I
had been wanting to do but that he's
never really seen we talked about it a
little bit back on our giallo show that
we did a while ago even though it's not
really a July we'll kind of get into
that but the movie I'm talking about of
course is the 1977 horror classic
Suspiria now this is not only one of my
favorite horror movies but also one of
my favorite movies in general it's just
a fantastic creepy atmospheric
nightmarish kind of movie that's just
like really beautiful to look at now it
must be said that if you are a fan of
gritty realism in your horror films
something like that then probably you
will not really dig Suspiria because
Suspiria is famously a little short on
plot but it is actually just it's kind
of all about the visuals and about the
aesthetic and stuff like that it does
have a plot it does make some semblance
of sense like it does have a story but
the story the narrative even kind of the
characters take a little bit of a
backseat to just the overwhelming visual
aesthetic of it and the overwhelming
like creepy atmosphere this kind of
surrealistic atmosphere that he's trying
to produce now the movie the plot such
as it is it's very simple it deals with
an American ballet dancer named Suzy
Banyan who is played by Jessica
and she comes from New York City to
Freiburg Germany to study at a
prestigious German dance academy now it
seems like something is sketchy right
from the start as soon as she gets to
the school she gets there and during a
rainstorm and she gets to the school and
as she's getting out of a cab and
getting up to the door she sees the door
fly open and this girl is kind of
standing in the doorway and it looks as
though she's yelling to someone that's
inside the building but she can't really
hear what she says because it's storming
and it's windy and there's too much
noise and then this woman like just
takes off and the door closes behind her
and Susy is trying to get in she kind of
you know goes to the intercom it was
like hey it's Suzie Banyan you I'm
expected and all this other stuff and
then the voice on the intercom was like
we don't know who you are go away and
stuff like that so
Suzie can't get in she has to go to a
hotel presumably for the night and
everything like that
now after that happens then we follow
the girl that was running out of the
school now she is running through the
woods and you can see there's a very
very cool shot where Suzie is in the cab
like going to a hotel or whatever and
she looks over and just sees this woman
like running through the trees with like
lightning flashes and stuff like that
and this woman proceeds to the apartment
building of a friend of hers she tells
her friend that that she discovered
something horrible at the school and all
that she thinks she's in danger and all
this other kind of stuff and then what
follows after that is probably one of
the most famous kill sequences probably
in horror history it's just this
beautifully like Baroque extended kind
of murder scene with these crazy
gorgeous interiors and just this kind of
just these kind of crazy super saturated
colors and the woman it's very gruesome
it's very over-the-top it's very violent
um you know she gets stabbed a lot of
times there's even a shot of her chest
open and like the the knife like going
into her heart you know which is like
open like her beating heart and then you
know she gets hung and then her friend
also dies would like she falls through a
stained glass window and or a stained
glass ceiling rather and like all the
glass comes down and
cuts up the friend that was running down
below it's just this crazy it's it
doesn't make any logical sense really
but it's a gorgeous gorgeous sequence
and it's very tense and it's very you
know and all this other stuff so then
after that happens then we go back to
the main character who is Susie Banyan
she gets to the school the next day
everything's fine the you know she meets
the device directress and one of the
instructors and everything like that and
you know they kind of act like oh no big
and everything sorry nobody lets you in
or whatever I don't know why that
happened and then they tell her like
pretty much because the cops are there
and stuff and they said oh well the girl
that you saw leaving last night was
named Pat and she had gotten expelled
and then she went and got herself
murdered and they kind of victim blame a
little bit like oh well you know that's
what happens when you get into
questionable friendships and stuff like
that so you know they're they're just
kind of trying to blow it off now as the
movie goes on Susie starts to suspect
that something weird is going on in the
school she makes friends with this girl
named Sarah and Sarah was actually
friends with Pat the girl that got
murdered and Pat had began to suspect
that there was something really sinister
going on at the school and she was
trying to investigate and all this other
stuff when she got murdered
you know suspiciously now there was us
there's also some stuff going on with
Susie's like the more she kind of delves
into this mystery of what's going on at
this school the more you know though the
whole thing seems kind of sinister where
you know initially she was supposed to
room off campus with this other student
like in an off-campus apartment but then
she ends up getting sick after this
really weird woman like flashes this
thing in her face and she starts getting
really dizzy and disoriented and starts
to pass out and so after that you know
the the people who run the school or
like well you can't live off campus you
have to stay here you know you have to
be under medical care and all this other
kind of stuff and they keep bringing
food to her room and stuff and she
suspiciously starts getting really
drowsy and all this other kind of crap
so as I said her and Sarah are kind of
investigating Sarah evidently had a
bunch of notes that Pat had taken
because Pat was trying to investigate
what was going on at this school and she
gave them to Sarah
or she got murdered but then when Sara
wants to show them to Susie they
disappear so obviously somebody there's
some kind of plot going on some kind of
conspiracy against people that look too
hard into stuff that's going on at this
school so as it goes on it comes to
light that Susie has actually been being
drugged by all this food and wine and
stuff that they're bringing her because
of her ailment sarah has taken to
investigating on her own now Sarah also
gets murdered in another very famous
sequence again that doesn't really make
any logical sense but who cares because
you know it's Argento it's Suspiria you
just have to roll with it
you know she gets trapped in a room by
somebody that's stalking her and they
try to get in and she climbs out a
window and falls into another room that
is inexplicably filled to the brim with
razor wire so she is in there and she's
like struggling to get out of the razor
wire and it's really horrible and stuff
like that that she gets her fruit slit
now after that happens so Susie does not
see that happen because she's been
drugged and she's sleeping but then the
next day suspiciously miss Tanner who
was one of the instructors very scary
woman she tells me well Sarah just took
off she didn't tell anybody where she
was going you know whatever so after
that Susie starts getting super
suspicious so she goes to a psychiatrist
who Sarah had been going to and this is
his name is Frank Mandel and he's
actually played by Udo Kier this was one
of his early film roles he's very young
in this and he's only in it for a few
minutes and he tells Susie that this
school in Freiburg Germany was founded
in the 1800s by this woman named Helena
Marcos and she was a Greek and she came
there and there was rumors that she was
a witch and she was called the black
queen so she talks to him and that she
talks to this other guy like who seems
to be some kind of scholar or something
like that and he tells her about witches
and he says he thinks they're real and
they're dangerous and stuff like that
and he gives Susie the important detail
that a coven cannot survive without its
queen so near me the end of the movie
Susie has decided to I mean because one
of the things that they figured out was
it's they said that Oh all the teachers
and stuff like that leave at the end of
the day like after dinner and stuff like
that but they started to
think that maybe they don't because
they've been hearing their footsteps
like going down into some part of the
building where they don't know where it
is so Susie decides that she's going to
follow them one night now when she gets
into the office of the vice director s
who's named Madame Blanca she's played
by Joan Bennett she suddenly remembers
what Pat the girl that was running from
the school when she first got there at
the beginning of the movie she finally
remembers or figures out what Pat was
saying what she was yelling to the other
person in the building and it had to do
with secret behind the blue iris turned
the blue one it said so when she's in
Madame Blanks office she sees that
there's a blue iris painted on the wall
there's actually her several irises
painted on the wall but she sees a blue
one she turns it in a secret passage
opens she goes back in the secret
passage and it turns out spoiler alert
that all of the teachers and everyone
that works at the school stuff it's a
coven of witches so she sees them she
hears them plotting to kill her and
stuff like that and she kind of stumbles
into another bedroom and in this bedroom
this is like super creepy super creepy
scene she sees this woman like behind
all these curtains like sitting up
behind Ben she's gets a horrible froggy
voice but this is Helena Markos who's
obviously very very old so Helena Markos
actually brings Sarah back from the dead
to kill Susie but before that can happen
Susie picks up this spike there was like
this kind of really really cool
sculpture of a peacock and all of its
feathers like all of its tail feathers
are made up like these spikes with like
crystals on the end and so she picks
this spike up and she ends up stabbing
Helena Marcus the Queen which actually
kills everyone in the coven and actually
makes the entire building come crumbling
down and become engulfed into flames now
that was the plot synopsis like I said
who does have a story it does have a
plot it is you can follow it a lot of
reviews I read of this movie are like oh
well it doesn't have a plot or but but
it does it does have a plot it's mostly
the murder scenes and stuff like that
that don't make a hell of a lot of sense
but that's just because like I said
Darya gent owes movies he's more
concerned with how they look and he's
more concerned with kind of establishing
a sort of dreamlike sort of logic or a
nightmarish kind of look
and kind of setting up these really
elaborate like murder set pieces and
stuff like that so he's not super
concerned about whether um you know oh
that person wouldn't have done that or
you know that that kill wouldn't have
happened that way or anything like that
he's just very concerned about about the
aesthetics of all of it and I want to
get a little bit into kind of the
inspirations behind this film because I
think that kind of brings a little bit
of depth to the analysis and everything
like that no actually Dario Argento got
some of the idea for this movie from an
essay by Thomas De Quincey which was
written in the 1800s called Suspiria d
profundus or sighs from the depths
because that's what Suspiria mean sighs
it's Latin and in this book there is a
section called Levana and Our Lady of
Sorrows and in this mythos it posits
that just as there are you know three
mythological fates and three
mythological Grace's there are also
three Sorrows represented by women one
of these is mater Suspiria room who is
the mother of sighs one of these is
mother lacrimarum the mother of tears
and one of these is mater tenebra erm
the mother of darkness or the mother of
shadows now most people will know if you
know anything about Italian cinema
Suspiria is actually part one in a sort
of loose trilogy called the three
mothers trilogy the second movie was
Inferno which came out in 1980 which was
about moderate enna Braham and that was
set in New York and the third movie
mother of Tears obviously about moderate
lacrimarum that came out in 2007 and was
set in Rome now the whole entire mythos
of this three mothers story or at least
how Dario Argento wrote it was that
these three women are essentially
witches and they have home bases in
various cities around the world from
which they you know unleash various
evils upon the world and things like
that so right from the start you're
getting a very mythological a fairy tale
kind of aesthetic kind of vibe to this
sort of movie and that's kind of what he
wanted to get at now he actually
co-wrote the screenplay with Dario
Nickelodeon at the time and she was
super into fairy tales particularly Snow
White and Bluebeard and stuff like
she wanted to kind of do something like
that she had also had a nightmare which
was pretty much the final scenes of the
movie where Suzy is in Helena Marcus's
bedroom and the outline of the witch and
all this other kind of stuff so that was
actually based on a nightmare that Daria
Nickelodeon now Dario Argento has also
said that he wanted this movie to be
essentially like a live-action
old-school Disney cartoon he said he's
already been fascinated with Snow White
and so he wanted this to kind of evoke
that kind of fairy tale sort of feel and
to get the look that he wanted he
actually used a Technicolor process
which was kind of going out of fashion
at the time this was actually one of the
last films to be filmed using this
particular Technicolor process but it's
the same I believe it's called
imbibition or something like that it was
the same method that was used for like
The Wizard of Oz and Gone with the Wind
where the colors are like supersaturated
and like almost surreal looking like
everything looks kind of like a cartoon
or you know like a paper cutout and
that's really what he wanted because he
wanted to evoke that kind of unrealistic
like artificial sort of look so it would
almost be like otherworldly kind of or
you know an uncanny sort of nightmarish
kind of look he has also said that that
he was traveling around Europe in
various European cities and he became
fascinated by the idea of the magic
triangle which is the spot where the
where France Germany and Switzerland
meet in the middle and evidently there
was an occultist named Rudolf Steiner
who kind of established in a community
there so he kind of got into the whole
occult thing and that was kind of his
contribution to it with that and Snow
White and everything like that and then
dhari and Nickelodeon about wanting to
do something very fairy tale s with
witches you know something like Alice in
Wonderland or Bluebeard or something
like that so those two things combined
together to sort of give Suspiria the
feeling that it has and as I said this
movie it's easily one of the most
beautiful movies to look at I've ever
made really every single frame of it is
just a
this gorgeous composition with like
these really really saturated like
shafts of primary colors or it does it
does not look realistic in the slightest
I mean hardly any of the scenes look
realistic everything is just super
saturated super baroque all of these
kind of all of the interiors are just
like way over the top and just like all
these crazy colors and patterns and
stuff like that and it's just a gorgeous
gorgeous movie and actually I kind of
want to add like a little personal side
note here I'm such a big fan of this
movie that my old house that I used to
live in I actually decided to do the
entire motif of the interior of the
house in a caesarian thing so each room
was painted like a different
supersaturated primary color like I had
a red room at a Blue Room I had a green
room and then the doors I painted all
the doors black then I painted like
these kind of Art Deco looking insects
like a lot of the doors if you see
enough in the movie a lot of the doors
have these kind of red stained glass in
sets that are kind of like a you know
like an art deco kind of design and I
painted them to look like that and it
looked super cool if I do say so myself
so really I have to say like I said make
this movie kind of the classic that it
is you know like I said the plots very
simple the characterization is very
simple you know it's very much like a
fairy tale so it's not you know super
deep or anything like that doesn't
really have any larger implications
really or anything of that nature it's
just kind of like supposed to be an
aesthetic experience which it definitely
is there are a lot of things I really
like about this movie I particularly
like Jessica Harper as the main
character she is really really perfectly
cast in this actually Dario Argento
asked her to be in the movie after he
saw her in Phantom of the paradise Brian
De Palma's infamous cult movie and he
had liked her in that and he wanted her
to be in this movie because as I said he
was trying to make something that evoked
Snow White so Jessica Harper comes off
very much like that she's very very
small very petite very thin but she has
this really beautiful face and he's
really
big wide eyes so she looks very naive
and very fragile but also comes across
as having hidden depths or hidden
strengths and and I think that works
very well in the role now I thought this
was interesting because the the role of
Sarah the supporting role who plays who
Susie's friend dari and Nickelodeon is
actually supposed to play that part she
Daria Nickelodeon I said was Dario
Argento's girlfriend at the time and
helped him read many screenplays
she has also started a bunch of his
older movies but she actually got sick
and she couldn't do it so they had a
Stefania Cassini come in instead another
thing I have to call out for this is the
musical score which is justifiably
famous it's by the prog rock band goblin
who Dario Argento worked with a lot and
just the music in this is just fantastic
it's just so evocative it just goes with
it just perfectly this and like I said
that's kind of one of the things I love
about this movie is jet it's just the
whole Gestalt of it the whole aesthetic
of it it just all fits together like a
puzzle and it's just everything came
together in this one beautiful gorgeous
package and it was just like lightning
in a bottle he didn't really it's sad to
say this was you know one of his earlier
movies but I don't think he ever
recaptured the magic of this film which
is kind of a shame he came close a few
times but I really think this was his
masterpiece as it was his magnum opus
and I don't think he ever topped it
after that now as I said this this movie
has to I don't really want to call them
sequels they because you don't have to
see them all it's not like it's not like
a continuing story it's more like three
separate stories set within the same
mythos you know I mean so you don't have
to see one to see the other you won't
miss anything or anything like that
because they're very different they
stand on their own so it's it's only a
very loose trilogy now in fur now as I
said came out in 1980 it was very
similar to Suspiria very similar with
the lighting actually maybe even a
little bit more over-the-top with the
lighting and everything like that it was
a bit glassy or looking at
have the exact same process that have
been used for Suspiria little made a
little less sense I thought but it had
some really really gorgeous scenes
really really nice so I like that one as
well now I saw for a mean for a long
time this was supposed to be a trilogy
like I said because it was the three
mothers and for a long time people
thought he was never going to finish it
but then finally he made mother of tears
in 2007 and even though well I saw it
once like shortly after it came out
maybe a year after it came out and I
remember it being disappointing which I
kind of figured it would be because like
I said pretty much after I think the
Stendhal syndrome was maybe the last
movie of his that I liked after that I
kind of felt like they went seriously
downhill like I really didn't like the
card player and I guess sleepless was
alright I haven't seen the one he made
that's just called jello so I can't
comment on that but I remember mother
tears being disappointing I will have to
revisit it at some point because I don't
really I just remember not really liking
it when I saw it and thinking oh that's
kind of a shame and wishing that he
would have completed the trilogy back in
the 80s so it would have hung together
better because to me it seemed like
Suspiria an inferno obviously look like
they go together they you know they
visually they're very similar they look
the same they have the same kind of
theme and everything like that you know
the one that he made in 2007 just seems
like it doesn't belong and so like I
said that's kind of a shame that he
waited so long to make it because I
think you know that the time had passed
to do that now this movie like I said is
generally beloved in horror circles and
it's kind of seeped into the popular
culture in a lot of ways there's a lot
of bands named after songs tons of songs
and stuff like that have sampled goblins
score the main theme from this movie
which is fantastic I'll put a little bit
of it at the end because I just I loved
that piece of music so much you know
there's been references to it in other
movies and TV shows and stuff like that
so it's really even though it's still a
cult film I feel like it's really kind
of seeped into the popular consciousness
in a lot of ways and actually I this is
actually the first time I'm mentioning
this on the show but I have been
fascinated with doing something you know
the
looks kind of suspect or anything like
that so I actually have designed a card
game it's not really based on Suspiria
it's more it's more like a
murder-mystery based on a whole j.lo
aesthetic and I'm hoping to get that
uploaded soon and then I want to you
know order a copy and you know play it
through a few times and maybe make some
tweaks and stuff like that but actually
the game is all designed I've designed
all the cards and you know written the
rules and everything like that so you
know when that comes out I'll let
everybody know if they're interested in
it because I'm super into Italian horror
I love jell-o movies and I just love the
whole look of them and I wanted to do
something that was kind of reminiscent
of that although I should argue and I
said I got into this a little bit on our
jello show too that even though and even
on Suspiria Wikipedia page you know it's
classified as a giallo I guess it could
be considered that and certainly Dario
Argento previous to Suspiria was largely
known for making for his jello films
which are kind of you know hallmarks of
the genre nowadays you know he obviously
made Bert with a crystal plumage he made
for flies on gray velvet he made cat and
ninetails and he made deep red which has
actually considered one of the best
jell-o jell-o movies of all time and
Suspiria was kind of his first movie
where he wanted to go in a different
direction as I said you can probably you
can classify Suspiria as a jello if you
want to I won't be mad at promise but in
a way I think it's kind of a different
animal it has some jell-o elements such
as the clue given at the beginning of
the movie that the protagonist can't
quite remember what it was and is trying
to spend some movie trying to figure it
out because that's like the key that
unlocks the whole thing there is that
kind of aspect you know there's the
aspect of the very stylized violent
killings you know a series of killings
that you don't know who's doing them and
stuff like that but honestly it seems to
me more like a straight supernatural
nightmarish fairy tale type horror movie
it doesn't really have a lot of the
police procedural kind of aspects that
that a jello would usually have even
though it has some overlapping elements
so I don't think I would call it a jello
strictly but I'm not going to get angry
people want to want to call it that
another couple things I'd like to
comment on just one thing I'd like to
comment on if you're not used to
watching Italian horror movies Italian
movies from this period for some reason
they are all dubbed they just did them
that I guess they felt it was easier
things like that so pretty much all of
Dario Argento's movies have been over
dubbed and it's especially noticeable in
Suspiria because well what they did was
on the set because some of the actors
were Americans some were English some
were Italian some were German so what
they did was they had everyone just
speak their native language on the set
and then later they over dubbed everyone
into English some of them using their
own voices some of them not hilariously
you don't care who you know is almost as
famous for his voice as anything else I
was overdubbed with an American accent
which some people think is very funny
but you know if you're not if you don't
know who to care is or anything like
that it won't seem that jarring or
anything like that but in a way I kind
of feel like the dubbing in Italian
movies almost like kind of adds to the
charm because it's almost kind of like
especially in Suspiria which is kind of
a surrealist or horror movie anyway so
it almost kind of adds that another
little aspect of the uncanny and if you
don't really know it's dubbed then
you're just like why is everybody it
just seems really weird and you can't
really put your finger on why and stuff
like that so it kind of adds to the
whole surrealism of the movie which I
really like now I want to speak briefly
here about there have been rumors
circulating since 2008 I think that this
movie is going to be remade now I am NOT
super happy about this I'm you know I'm
pretty crabby about remakes in general I
just wish people would make original
horror movies I mean I don't have a
problem if you want to make a remake
pick a movie that was like a good idea
but was poorly executed the first time
around that you know it didn't come out
so good and stuff like that maybe make
it if you think you could make it better
but don't take a movie that's a classic
like The Texas Chainsaw Massacre for
example or something like that and try
to remake that because why that is just
pointless I feel like it's pointless and
they're just doing it as a cash grab and
it's just stupid and it's never going to
be as good you're
we're gonna capture that same atmosphere
particularly from horror movies of the
70s have a very particular style a very
particular aesthetic and you can't redo
that so as I said there's been rumors
going around that Suspiria was going to
be remade now initially the guy that was
supposed to direct it was named David
Gordon Green and I guess the production
kind of went round and round and there
were legal issues and stuff like that
and around 2013-2014 he said I don't
think it's ever gonna get made now and
everything like that and you know all
cult horror fans around the world
breathed a sigh of relief however just a
couple of years ago it was announced
that the remake was actually going
through it's going to be a different
director an Italian director named Luca
Guadagnino I hope I pronounced that
right he announced at the 72nd Venice
Film Festival that he was going to
direct the remake Tilda Swinton is gonna
be in it Dakota Johnson is gonna be in
it possibly ray Fiennes I do not know
how I feel about it I don't really want
to [ __ ] on something I haven't seen but
I just really do not think this is a
good idea one promising sign is that
he's going to set the movie in 1977 when
the original movie came out and he's
going to set it in Berlin the original
was actually set in Munich so it might
be alright in that sense but I've also
heard that it's not going to have the
visual look of the original so to me
again that seems pointless because the
thing about Suspiria is that it's whole
thing is its atmosphere its colors the
visual style of it that you know the
soundtrack everything like that
all of it goes together and I don't
think that the movie can be separated
from those aspects it's not so in a way
I think it's a movie that really can't
be remade because if you do it exactly
like the old one then that is also
pointless because we already have the
old one so why we do it just the same
but if you're going to remake it without
those crazy lights and those crazy
colors and just those you know those
gorgeous like grotesque murder scenes
and stuff like that if you're going to
make it without that then it's not
Suspiria anymore you know what I mean so
me it just seems like a pointless
exercise it's like if they want to make
a movie about a witch's coven just write
a different one I mean it could be
similar it could be inspired by but if
you're not gonna make it look like
Suspiria then it's not Suspiria and if
you do make it look like Suspiria then
you're just treading over ground that's
already been done so I really don't
think that there's any reason for it to
be remade and I really wish they
wouldn't have done it but evidently the
principal photography it has been filmed
apparently it was actually finished last
year last March but I don't know when
it's going to be released last I heard
that like I said the filming had been
finished
Jessica Harper does have a part in it so
she's not not in the same role she's not
reprising the role obviously but um she
has like some kind of cameo or something
like that in it which you know that's
cool I love her and stuff like that but
I don't know I just think the whole
thing is it is a bad idea I will
probably see it even though after I say
it I'm sure I wish I hadn't seen it
because I just I don't know I don't know
how it could be good even if it's good
it will still piss me off because you
know why didn't they just make another
witch movie and stuff like that but you
know whatever like I said I haven't seen
it so I can't super [ __ ] on it yet but I
just I think it's a stupid idea from the
get-go and I just really wish they
hadn't done it but I guess it's too late
now so anyway um if you were a horror
fan and you haven't already seen this
which would shock me if you hadn't but
maybe like a lot of younger people
haven't seen it because I know how how
that goes you know most of the movies
from the 70s and stuff like that maybe
so like people younger people that came
up with horror movies haven't got around
to seeing all the old ones yet like I
said if you're into gritty
straightforward type of horror or you
know stuff that's like plot focused or
character focused or something like that
then you might find this a little
strange because like I said it's more of
an experience you just kind of have to
you know sit back and let it wash over
you'll all these you know these
beautiful visuals and stuff like that it
is very creepy it does have some very
creepy scenes particularly the ones with
Helena Markos because she's got this
creepy voice and this creepy snore and
all this other kind of stuff but it's
you know it's really a classic classic
horror movie for a reason and if you
haven't seen it I would definitely
recommend it as I said the two
subsequent movies inferno I would
definitely
recommend mother of tears and you don't
really have to see it I didn't think it
was that great like I said I'd have to
see it again cuz it's probably been
eight or nine years since I've seen it
and I just I remember not liking it but
seriously check it out if you haven't
already as one of my favorite movies
ever definitely one of my favorite
horror movies and that will do it for
this hopefully last movie review that is
Tom 'less he should be back the evening
that this comes out so hopefully that
will go okay I know I said that last
time but hopefully for real this time
but if you like the show remember to
Like share subscribe on all your social
media if you would like to support the
show with a small donation then you can
go to our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
if you don't like patreon you can go to
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
WordPress com and there is a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account as ever stay
on the lookout for our regular episodes
which come out every Tuesday and Tom
should be back for the next one
and until next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]